so good to see you
it's been a couple years but I think
about you all the time man
well you're just you're out there you
have more energy you are more relentless
than almost anybody I've ever met
it's crazy you were just saying that
you're doing how many lectures I got to
200 cities and sometimes more than one
lecture per city sometimes to a you know
different cities in writing day you know
over ten months yeah yeah so when people
say you know yeah I'd really like to eat
better but I try too much nobody travels
as much as you do I don't think I've
ever met anybody who travels well but
it's just our mounting like a three year
book cycle so it's only one out of three
years so I write a book a year then I'm
on the road for a year but then I got
you know and then I got a write three
years worth of videos for nutrition
facts and then I write the next book so
do you whiteboard that all out of
advance so you know what your books are
down the line and all that so like 20 42
or something right I am and when do you
how do you apportion that so you have
all the videos coming out on nutrition
facts right you got the books you got
the lectures you're never home and when
you are home you're on a walking desk
like how does this work yeah yeah no no
so people like well I love the video you
like how'd you do the video today you
were on the plane as if you know I'm
like it's like I did that video a year
ago literally right so I do I script
three years where the videos every three
years um and so you just hope and pray
that broccoli is still good for you next
year because you know it's right in
stone has that ever happened where the
science has changed and you had to pull
the video video yeah yeah I mean usually
in in in there's an even stronger
evidence or you know in the same kind of
direction but now there's we finally
have something that really clinches it
yeah more than more than anything rice
but yeah well you were one of my very
first guests on this show episode seven
all the way down then we did a second
one where there was a technical snafu we
were at some conference and we did it
and it didn't record that's only
happened like three or four times in
seven years but you were you you fell
victim about the trend
and then the last time that we did this
I think was four years ago so it seems
like yesterday you're in my heart what
is the the current lecture all about
because I know you you're constantly do
you change it for every audience or you
have kind of a lockdown thing that you
do every year yeah so so now so I used
to a new talk every year because I'm
gonna say always traveling every year
but now I'm only traveling you know
after the new book so I just have the
new book talk and so for new audiences
they get the last book talk uh-huh but
for audiences have already seen it the
how not to die talk I give the how not
to die it the weight loss talk that's
right I'm doing now so this is the new
mic I actually like the old one I mean
so my the last dog how not to die talks
is my favorite talk I mean she says more
humor than any other time een so my
preference and it's like perfectly
memorized like hey I can like you know
think about my grocery list while I'm
giving it like I mean it's just like
definitely write and put it so but and
in the the new but you know I'm reading
off the notes on a podium I missed you
know it's gonna be a while before and
just want to get really good at it
so I'll never get it's like like a
stand-up comedian you got a date you
tape your special and you gotta retire
the material it's all over but in your
case this material it has a longer shelf
life though this stuff doesn't doesn't
necessarily age you know it's crazy so
how not to die is selling better now
than it did the month after release back
2016 when this old scene over 3/4 of a
million copies right yeah about yeah
down and hundred percent of all proceeds
go to charity charity for all my books
yeah we're talking a lot of money yeah
yeah this last one I donated more than a
million dollars this year Wow and I
would suspect that that a big part of
that other than just being you know
compassionate in your heart is to
basically rebut the argument that you're
conflicted you have you're selling a
book so you're you're you're anchored in
this position and no matter what the
evidence says you've got a toe this line
because you're financially incentivized
right although there's still the idea
logic
call kind of conflicts of interest so
even even people that aren't necessarily
profiting off of their work I mean they
still may be wedded to some idea I'm so
it doesn't completely divorce me from
the right you know you know concern over
bias but but yeah I mean with so much
the the corrosive corruption of
commercial influences well let me talk
about that we then I mean medicine in
general but nutrition in particular
we're you know this I mean the you know
the confirmation bias is just so extreme
in no other field have I ever seen such
a thing it's pretty bananas right now I
feel like there's a mushroom cloud of
information like if you're in the
Twittersphere it's just it's insane
the siloed you know kind of tribal wars
that are going on right now are so
emotional and acerbic it's it's quite
toxic so how do you I mean you post your
stuff I've noticed like you don't engage
in any of that you kind of just stay
above the fray ya know that yeah and
that was a conscious decision to be like
look this is all the science that I
could find on this and so there's unless
I mean and so the only you'll notice on
nutrition fact the only comments I
respond to is what about this study or
you know what about this study you know
and B because it's very possible I maybe
I missed that stuff I mean you know I
mean we got a huge research staff now
but you know I want to make sure that
this is that I like I I put that into
the into the calculus when I came out
with what I consider the best available
balance of evidence and so it's like
this is the sign so there's really
nothing anyone can say you know I mean
and so and and it's really not like you
know most of my videos I turn really
hard to be like this is now I have no
opinion on this here's the science make
up your own mind
haha I mean it convinced me to do X Y &
Z but if you're not convinced by the
evidence you know wait till you know
Rison else drops well you must you must
get the criticism that you're
cherry-picking studies like you have to
make a decision about what studies
you're gonna highlight in these videos
right so that's why that's why it takes
me forever to write the videos because I
have to make sure so it's not just some
new study but we're that new study it
this in the context of every other study
that's ever been published ever right I
mean so many studies get published a
year well I mean so just like legitimate
so well so in the in obesity just just
in the field of obesity there's over a
hundred thousand studies every so that's
like you know I mean so it's like you
know I go to sleep and I'm already like
you know I'm Way behind you do sleep I
I'm working on it but you talked about
that in the new book I know how do you
practice it is so depressing to look at
the sleep medicine literature because I
just realized oh oh that's it I'm gonna
that horrible things gonna happen to me
oh is the one blind spot that's yeah
yeah but I mean I just I find myself I'm
so much less productive when I'm
unconscious yeah that you know so
thousand studies a year on obesity alone
100 thousands a hundred thousand oh my
god you even weed through this and
figure out so you know what's what's
worth looking at and you know what's
really worth exploring and digging into
and and and ultimately I would imagine
deconstructing at times to figure out
what's you know what what holds up to
your standards and what doesn't so there
was over so we have over 100 research
volunteers that churn through that's how
we can get through tens and thousands of
studies every year just because we have
you know all these like retired docs
that are just sitting around and just
have a hobby of helping me out basically
and so any one time we have nearly 200
active volunteers and that and and and
so I mean we can just we can just xirn
through so much and you know I have
access I have people in libraries every
major library anywhere who will pull any
study from and you know so I have
someone that will just go to the NIH you
know largest medical library in the
world and pull any gold stud isn't even
online so I have access to everything
and just in this incredibly privileged
position to be able to you know but
that's assuming the literature all says
one thing right the problem with thee
the reason why this new obesity book the
weight loss book was such a bear the
hardest thing I've ever taken on in my
life was because it's incredibly
conflicting mm-hmm and so uh if you know
hunters they say one things that under
700 say they say another thing if say
well we saying what is it about the way
they did the studies the the populations
the exclusion criteria like what was it
that you could arrive at such disparate
conclusions using very similar kind of
methods and that took four four so
simple questions like skip breakfast or
not skip breakfast and exercise before
after a meal or I mean these like really
like these are thousand article research
questions there's a thousand articles on
and you're just like wait a second this
is two pages of the book maybe what
maybe it's a little sidebar and it's all
others who want to know should I eat
breakfast all night and no you know I
could alive fast I get a lot of that to
do that I think that's that's what
everyone's like okay I don't care I know
right be my guru right um and that with
that but you know anyone fall I mean
that's that's the antithesis of what I
want to you know that's the problem is
people just you know just follow what
someone says and as if we were born with
this knowledge I mean we I mean when it
comes to something as life-and-death
important as to what feed yourself and
your family then if there's anything we
should any decision we should make best
based on evidence it should be something
like that if you're online buying a
toaster then the random opinions of
strangers may actually be really useful
like oh I like this one okay but when it
but you know when I was when I was in
practice and so we came to I say well
you know why are you eating this
particular path someone at the gym told
me to you know eat this way right I'm
like really I mean you're checkout aisle
magazine is the reason that you're
feeding your kids that I mean you
realize that what we is the number one
cause of death and disability in the
United setting the most important
decision we make is what we put in our
mouths and so if there's any decision
that should be built based on evidence
and we should demand
and evidence and not just a citation but
show me the evidence I want to see it
for myself to make sure you didn't take
it out of context I mean that this is
what and so that's that you and I both
know well that even the most
well-intentioned consumer who begins to
explore this whether online or whatever
they're gonna find conflicting
information out there and it appears to
have equal merit it's like it's like
when you turn on the news and there's
ten people yelling at each other at the
same time even if one of them is
completely Looney Tunes it appears that
they're standing on equal footing right
so you know you can find studies that
will support whatever perspective or
confirmation bias that you have and it
becomes very difficult for that well
meaning you know intelligent person to
separate you know the chaff from you
know the cream when it comes to this
this is where you come in but even then
it's like all right well you're sifting
through thousands and thousands of these
studies and realizing well this is
complicated and even even good science
seems to conflict you know how do you
make heads or tails of that I can't
judge somebody who's like you know dr.
Greger just like what is it tell me give
me the good man no you don't say you
know it's like that and there's lots of
problems with the you know peer-reviewed
medical literature you know it's like
that I don't know if Winston Churchill
left it actually said it but attributed
to Winston Churchill you know democracy
worst form of government except for all
the others right and it's the same thing
I'm just like the peer-reviewed
scientific literature it's the best we
have I mean it's the worst we have
except for all the others I mean that's
what else can we do but abide by you
know what's been you know published in
the medical literature but there's lots
of problems with industry bias and you
know funding effects and and so that's
why you really need the first thing I do
when I look I study who paid for the
study where is it coming from just so
you can read it with that lens doesn't
mean it's necessarily bad studies may
still be a good study still be a good
study but you want to read it with that
you know to you want to you know take it
with extra-special grain of salt and
look at the materials methods really
make sure they didn't create this they
didn't produce the study in a way too
get some desired result they were
actually coming into it really you know
look right learn something and despite
the fact that you've read countless
thousands of these studies I mean you've
been you know you've been on board with
the whole food plant-based diet for
decades at this point do you ever come
across a study that contravenes some
long-held truth that you've held like if
you ever had to mature update your
thoughts on things like how how is that
evolution bad yeah no look I mean anyone
who's saying the same thing about
nutrition that they're saying a few
years ago obviously hasn't been keeping
track the literature I mean the reason I
can do new I could do new videos every
day forever it's just because there's
this tremendous wealth of information
out there now usually is just kind of
nibbling at the edges like after how not
to die game out I realized that oh and I
was telling people oh you got to toast
your walnuts and sesame seeds it just
makes your kitchen smell so wonderful
that's great and they tasted wonderful
then this paper came out talked about
these AG es this advanced glycation in
prices glycotoxins found in high-fat
high-protein foods exposed to high dry
heat temperatures traditionally it's
like frankfurters and stuff and chicken
mcnuggets but knots you put them at
those temperatures and they create these
nasty I don't so I now I tell people to
eat the raw nuts but that's the nice
thing about a video where so I could
update I suppose the book which is
already out but um you know when
reprints we can get it but I mean little
things like these are like good buds but
I mean there you can find studies all
the time saying you know you know bacon
and butter is good for you just like the
tobacco lobby would come literally with
piles of studies to these congressional
hearings say this is not this is not the
research that says smoking is neutral
this is the literature saying smoking is
good for you it helps with Parkinson's
disease and ulcerative colitis and but a
lot of this is true because it's
immunosuppressive and serving autoimmune
disease you smoke you kill your immune
system your your autoimmune disease gets
better you phlegm every bell disease
gets better but these are legit studies
showing smoking beneficial now of course
that's not the best available balance of
evidence because you're gonna die
graphic death lung cancer but you can
but those studies exist and you can
cherry-pick them out
and that's why that's why you know every
single every everyday a video comes out
I send the video to every single
principal investigator of every article
I cite and be like excited here's your
research you know um in hopes that one
will be like you you you you
misinterpreted or whatever and I can
immediately you know kind of write so
when you when you get like what is your
response when somebody criticizes you
and says he's just you know he's a
plant-based guys always gonna be a
plant-based guy he's got his own
confirmation bias this is a guy who's
really just an animal rights activist
who's who shrouded himself in a medical
frock I mean it's like I mean it's like
you know some some you know
pulmonologist saying oh you're just an
anti cigarette guy I mean that your only
reason you're telling people not to
smoke again it's because you know you
have a well-known record of you were
against cigarettes ten years ago before
this study comes out Oh a new study
comes out saying smoke is bad for you
mr. anti cigarettes is they're at it
again
[Applause]
I mean the science is the science and
you know the the charges of
cherry-picking so for example there's
only one died ever proven to reverse
heart disease the majority of patients a
plant-based diet number one killer of
men and women like shouldn't that be the
default diet and to proven otherwise
only once so it's hard to cherry-pick
when there's only one cherry like
there's no other now in the future maybe
some new diet will be shown too but I
mean until that happens and this happens
over and over again
with multiple sclerosis and Crohn's
disease and on down the list nothing's
been shown to work better and there's
just I mean you know so right right I
mean listen you said it but the fact
that heart disease you know basically
kills more people than anything else and
this is the one protocol that actually
will not only prevent it but reverse it
if you have it like why are we even
exploring anything further and the fact
so it's amazing that it's so
controversial and the fact that can also
help prevent arrest to reverse other
leading killers type 2 diabetes and high
blood pressure we seem to make the case
for Plan B's eating just
simply overwhelming at this point I mean
if this alright if there's one thing you
need to know number one killer men and
women only died ever proven a person in
the majority patient's plant-based diet
so the only way that wouldn't argue for
it being the default die for everyone is
if it so dramatically increase your risk
of you know killers 2 through 15 or
something such that would overwhelm the
heart disease benefit and instead you
just see you tend to see a benefit
neutral effects across people right well
you've got to be thrilled to see this
movement this way of eating and living
you know kind of explode over recent
years I mean never before in your career
you know have we seen such a crazy
adoption rate which is super exciting
but there's also a lot of pushback now
and we have these sort of other diets
that are rising to the surface and and
you know challenging for their moment in
the Sun and and and it makes me realize
or I guess appreciate just how emotional
all of this is it's not it's it's really
not an information war as much as it is
a psychological war you know what I mean
like because you've spent decades
putting information I mean nobody puts
out more information about this than you
do and if somebody's resistant to that
that's their choice but I feel like the
battle really needs to be waged on how
to win hearts and mind and not just the
minds but the hearts you know what I
mean like huh what is what and I'm
interested in you know whether you have
thought about this you know with respect
to the newest book it's like weight loss
like everybody wants to lose weight
right but often it's not it's not the
information it's the implementation of
the information and and what gets in the
way of people taking that information
and putting it into action has to do
with their own psychological makeup and
you know the emotional landscape and you
know the the social construct in which
they live their lives you know one eye
you know at some of these you know
amazing plant-based nutrition health
care conferences now which now attract I
was right so it's just amazing you know
the number one question I have for
everyone
like how did you come across the
obviously didn't learn about it and in
medical school none of us did like how
did you come and most frequently the
answer I get is because a patient taught
them like so they've had these patients
forever and they've known their whole
families and they've had diabetes and
you know they're just trying to slow the
rate at which they go blind and lose
their kidney function and lower limbs
and then all of a sudden they come in
they're 20 pounds lighter they're there
they need to they're dramatically over
or medicated all of a sudden they have
to pull back all the drugs and that
doctors like what happened and the
patient says oh I saw folks over knives
or you know game changes some of the and
then all of a sudden um and I me and the
doctor in the back of their mind doctor
saying I've got like two thousand
patients just like you what is going on
and that's so and so great that it's
upside down oh my god and so a few tries
me crazy
and so I'm like wait a second I've got
to stack this big of peer-reviewed
scientific live randomized control
trials proving reversal of these
diseases yet it was one little anecdote
one person comes to you and then all
this uh but it's but it's but it's that
human connection where like storied
creatures like all the data in the world
you know all you know it'll you know
some people are open to that but other
people they just need to see it in front
of their face alright and so I note so
that's that's why I think the more
popular it gets the easier will be when
they see their friends and families the
transformations then it'll click that
and of course I'll be in the background
banging my head against the wall saying
how long is this this is the seventies
where a pentagon was it reverse of heart
disease in the 70s how many people have
died since then needlessly over a
hundred thousand people every year heart
disease in the United States alone that
much suffering
it should anger people right I mean the
the the the reaction to someone who just
doesn't have to go through you know open
our surgery anymore
isn't shouldn't be relief oh my god I
have to get my chest cracked open and
now I get to live long happy life and
see my grandkids grow up she'd be like
how why didn't anyone tell me this but
right I'm outraged outraged it's yeah
yeah of these two hundred cities that
you visit all the speeches that you give
many of them are at medical schools or
hospitals because I obviously like the
way to get to the root of this is to is
to educate medical students and create a
better ecosystem around care yeah train
the trainer's that's really what I'm
doing now is mostly talking to
professional audiences I'm talking
tonight at a Medical Center the and lots
of medical schools now but and that's
how much she started out my kind of
speaking career is going in fact that
was my goal speech every single medical
school every two years to hit every
single new grad coming out I have a
whole new generation of Doc's learning
this but I realized like that's too slow
like they're not they're still gonna be
in training for another five years then
they got to get out and then they I mean
so like people are dying now when it
comes to safe simple side-effect free
solutions like stop smoking eat
healthier you don't need your doctor to
tell you to do that we can take this
directly to the people with this kind of
democratization of information now
available and so I you know so then
that's how nutritionfacts.org got born
instead of forget the doctors you know
let them come around eventually we got a
right people are dying right now people
need to know and then of course it's up
to you it's your body your choice wanna
go smoke cigarettes book go bungee jump
into whatever you want but you know
there at least you should be you know
educated about the predictable
consequence of your actions other than
your unbridled enthusiasm for this one
of the things that's that that I like
about you and that's interesting about
you is that you really strive to stand
outside of dogma and you're not telling
people what to do you're just you're
you're basically in a very objective way
presenting the information and allowing
people to do with it as they will yeah I
mean that's always been really important
to me is and look and for whatever
reason there's no judgment I mean I
happen to have the background that
enabled me to do this work and to be Who
I am
I mean there are people struggling with
all sorts of things that you don't know
about and the fact that they're still
eating
you know crap on their home you know way
home from work I mean no idea what's
going on their lives they led them to
whatever but should they have the
opportunity to really you know whether
it's a health scare or whatever to be
I really need to clean up my act at
least there should be a place they can
go where here's the information this is
what I wish I learned in medical school
and you know do with it geek out on
nutrition fun I mean how many hours of
videos do you have on there now we have
thousands thousands over two thousand
videos now basically you go to the site
and you could just search whatever food
or whatever ailments and you've got it
covered
yeah yeah nobody video gonna be oh
there's always new stuff I'm constantly
I mean there's just always new yeah you
know and you know it's so I do it two
ways one through I run through all the
topics actually alphabetically anyone's
keeping my little close attention will
be like oh oh so the olive oil came
after the the nuts which came after they
you know yeah um but and then I just go
through and read all the every issue of
every single English language nutrition
journal in the world see because there
may be topics I don't need even know to
look up there's this yeah I mean all
sorts of new hormones and really
receptors and new I just working on the
plane on this CD 36 receptor whoa blew
my mind because right gets sidetracked
on that it sounds like an air it sounds
like a airplane to me like a c-130 in
terms of taking it to the people which
you've been doing the real needle mover
I think has been this slew of
documentaries that have come out over
the last
amaz'n of which is of course game
changers and you were the scientific
technical adviser on that movie right so
what did that look like what was your
involvement made that well I mean just I
mean certainly to take that first point
when I go around speak and ask people in
these you know for our book signing
lines so how do the it's what the health
its forks over knives is these these
documentaries are now just really yeah
yeah tremendous oversized effect right
and so if people if they're funders
interested in getting this you know
movement off the off the ground I think
that's a decent way to go yeah well
they're probably good investments these
movies do very well do and
so ya know so uh so yeah so I was
approached by James Wilkes Oh God like
seven years ago you know when it was
just you know an idea and and you know
if you've me for the for the film and
some like you know on some highway and
Santa Rosa or something in this noise
he's like a little whatever you know
like a little camcorder II kind of thing
in a hotel um and it was just an idea
but you can't say no to any opportunity
right so like poor Dean Ornish still
kicking himself for not being in Forks
Over knives because he was taking some
time off or whatever he just got to be
in everything and hope something helps
and and so so then here see it's
starting to get some momentum for the
film and and invited me back sit sorry
we got to throw all that footage away it
was crap before but now we actually have
real cameras and you know alright right
so then we you know do another thing and
actually happened once or twice more
than the like okay now we really have
money now we have like that fancy so I
when do like and then of course I get
cut out completely from the film which
is fine I wouldn't replace a second of
it I think so perfect but hopefully I'll
be in some DVD extra or something down
the road but um so but the role I could
play instead was to fact-check the film
uh-huh because I have an army I mean
that's what we do you're the perfect
person for that yeah yeah and and and we
actually behind the scene and I open
invitation to anyone writing a book
producing a film TV show anything come
to me I'll do it for free our whole team
I mean it's so important to me that we
don't say ridiculous stuff and people
throw the baby out with the bathwater I
mean the movement has said just
ridiculous crazy stuff
exaggerated stuff I mean I mean yeah it
doesn't help the movement to do that it
right and because it imperils the crowd
of bill and if you have and as if we
have to exaggerate anything we should
use the industry estimates for
everything the most lowball you know oh
oh yeah it's only fifteen hundred
gallons per pound of beef whatever water
you know according to the National
Cattlemen's Beef Association or whatever
I mean that's what I mean yeah it
boggles the mind so yeah that's so
critical that so a lot of the books that
you know I've
are written up and as long as as long
and we will do it as long as they're
willing to actually write so your your
job was really vetting all the science
so that there was no exaggerations and
that everything that was said and every
scene kind of you know met the met the
scientific in fact was conservative so
not just sticking to the consensus but
like on the conservative side of
anything let's not see anything the
science is so strong we don't need to
exaggerate we don't need to go anywhere
but beyond the you have solid ground
worst right and the the whole
erectile-dysfunction sequence was your
brainchild i was walk us through that
well so we mean so I had the data I had
the science but again you need to make
the science relatable you know I could
show you know a graph a table an amazing
table with a statistical significance
that alone would give you an erection
but that's is that's not gonna move a
visual sunny cinematic it's not
cinematic and so they kept asking how do
we make it how do we make it visual how
do we make it alive and so so I said
well let's do the lacked essence that
you know the the cloudiness of fat after
eating a meal in the serum and I knew
just from reading the the literature on
blood flow on into a few little function
that they had these ridges scan machines
with a name like ridges scan it's got to
be good and and so and so and now it's
actually being done legit why I mean in
a real study in fact I think by us Feld
but dr. oz Feld is now as the funding
he's actually gonna put it to the test
and a really you know tightly controlled
randomized fashion with a you know a
cadre of folks but again he was just
they wanted to show the example to you
know anyway right yeah but so latest
book how not to diet how dare you write
a book about weight loss can't believe
this right so how not to die is really
about sort of tackling preventing
reversing the you know the the sort of
top ailments chronic ailments that
people suffer from but of course a
is an ailment in and of itself were a
contributor to a variety of ailments
right so without sort of confronting
obesity head-on you're not really
getting you know you're not gonna move
the needle for people right so you got
it you got to get him to lose weight so
I did that yeah yeah so how not to die
fifteen leading causes of death just
went through one through 15 chapter I
needs talking rolled I'm a play in
preventing resting reversing so there's
a type 2 diabetes chapter obviously the
but but never took obesity on directly
and and it really required its own thing
so that mean yeah so you have to then
turn your focus into how to help people
lose weight right like what is the
science of weight loss and I would
imagine you know you had to confront
like a lot of things that we sort of
assume or take for granted that perhaps
maybe didn't turn out to be true like
like oh calorie and calorie out or you
know three meals a day or what you know
what there's so much conventional wisdom
around like here's how you lose weight
ABC so by immersing yourself in all of
this research like what surprised you
the most or what did you discover that
perhaps you know you didn't expect yeah
so in both ways some of the conventional
wisdom actually has real scientific
basis and only recently doesn't have a
real scientific basis so for years we've
just been saying that's stop talking out
of our butt but now oh that's actually
true we should you know breakfast like a
king you know lunch like a prince dinner
like a pop or kind of thing some of this
or you know drink water before a meal
very common kind of thing oh now we
actually have size it really does must
show beneficial effects but I think the
biggest the biggest challenge for me
just because this is not my field I mean
you know I just know from what I learned
in med school and this concept that a
calorie is a calorie right account from
one source is just as fattening is a
calorie from any other source I mean
this is kind of a trope broadcast by the
food industry to come absolved itself of
culpability but it's just not true like
you know 100 calories of chickpeas has a
different effect on body weight than 100
calories of chicken or Chiclets based on
absorption based on fiber content based
on all sort and even if you absorb the
same amount even accounting may still
not be a cow it depends
when you eat it in what context do you
know how fast you eat it
also I mean so I mean that just kind of
exploded like my concepts of mmm kind of
what we had learned in in in med school
so like this chronobiology have a whole
chapter on right service because this is
I'd never heard anything about this so
what I had known what we learned about
in in medical training is it's called
Karma therapeutics where if you give
chemotherapy at the right time of day
you actually have fewer side-effects and
it's more effective than giving at a
different time of day same dose same
drug I'm which which it's fascinating
but I hadn't taken it the log vehicle
conclusion what about chronal prevention
might exercise and and and and and you
know sleep patterns and meal patterns
also play a role if it has such a
dramatic effect
and indeed calories eaten in the morning
are less fattening the exact same food
eaten tonight the fewer calories after
sundown the better so they do these
states how it acts why's that well it's
because so for example in the morning
your body body has to to make glycogen
stores for the for the rest of the day
and in make instead of just using the
energy if you if you take the little
chains of sugars and starches and and
make them the glycogen in your muscles
and liver that's an energy intensive
process and then you break it back down
to be used later on and so the fact that
you're using energy to basically get the
energy right back it's kind of energy
intensive buzzing that's one of the
small reasons why eating in the morning
when you're when your body's you know
knows it's got a whole day ahead of it
where are you you know you have that the
glycogen building signal earlier in the
day but you know a lot of the
chronobiology stuff we just don't know
in terms of what exactly is going on but
everything from body temperature - you
know testosterone - cortisol levels
everything you know goes on this this
wild day Lusaka and then there's
seasonal cycles wheat lost you know it's
in the the weight you put on the kind of
winter months for for the for the
holidays may you have the pack
the pond how far the earth is from some
crazy right the rotation I'm so that was
the I mean that that yeah that just blew
me away so you can put people in 2000
calories exact same 2,000 calories
there's one meal it's breakfast or one
meal at supper the army did this and one
and the evening group same calories
gains weight and the breakfast group
loses with such insurance crazy and so
then that really opened my eyes
okay well now anything's possible and so
then really kind of dug deep and you
know came up just you know what are the
criteria for for optimum weight loss
like what would what would the optimum
weight loss that it look like from kind
of from the ground up just because um
originally how not to die it was gonna
be a chapter on each of the latest diet
trends um and just you know going
through what's the science behind each
but I realized the books coming out of
date before it even comes out you know
I'm part of the US News and World Report
you know diet panel you know and run a
week at dozens of new diets have never
heard about every year that we have to
go through and I just realized well wait
a second this that's not that right it's
like whack-a-mole so instead let's just
here's the criteria against which you
can look at any future diet and see you
kind of where would fall among this
range and then and then the second half
of the book is regardless of what you
eat there are you know kind of tips and
tricks they can and tweaks that can get
you to accept right like this water
thing and focusing on nutritional
density and caloric dilution things no
fancy that's the really the first part I
mean that's part of a good help my
weight loss diet weight loss techniques
but like the water right water pre
loading so if you drink two cups of
water before eating a whopper you'll
gain less weight then I mean so I mean
so it's regardless of what you eat
that's the whole second half and the
hope is people won't just kind of jump
to the second half it'll actually do a
safe sustainable nutritious healthy diet
but in terms of the foods to eat though
I mean it harkens back to the previous
book and it kind of Orient's around the
daily dozen it ended up ended up that
way based on those criteria like you
want to beat fiber-rich and you know
Loen added sugar isn't all that fat and
you know
bought a wrench and all they say and
it's the same you know vegetables and
kind of on down the list and that was
the that was the the either the
criticism with God from the daily diet
daily does an app that we released as
you know had a million downloads and
there's two camps of criticism one is Oh
My gods too much food I can't eat it all
and oh my god I can't because through
all this stuff make sure you get all of
that well I mean but it's aspirational
like you know it's just and you can you
know make a game and see how many you
can get if you don't do good one day you
can try better the next day and that was
actually this I mean I'm hoping to you
know after you checked off those box
there's only so much room for pepperoni
pizza at the end of the day I mean it's
it's this kind of it's this kind of eat
more approach but it's really hoping to
kind of actually push out some of the
less healthy options but the other group
of criticisms came in it's it's not
enough calories it's like look I'm
training there's no way I'm getting a
gun get enough calories eating this
concept I was like well look this is the
minimum you can eat more food I'm gonna
say this is all you can eat this is I
just want people to hit this but then I
realized wait a second Oh too much food
too few calories that sounds like a good
weight loss diet and the fact that these
are some of the healthiest foods on the
planet it's a good bonus as well right
did you come across some interesting
research on intermittent fasting because
that seems to be the thing that that you
know a lot of people are talking about
and thinking about and practicing right
now and I've had a couple people on the
podcast speak to it that's the biggest
chapter is the fasting janitor so much
information now I remember looking to
fasting because there's been a you know
common interest for for years people
have asked me about it anytime I only
want to say I don't know once ever even
if the most esoteric question in the
world I want it the next time someone
asked me that I'm gonna know an answer
to it and some people cast me about
fasting and there's no data and so
that's why if there's if there's if
there's a condition or food that you
can't find a Nutrition Facts that org
their number one reason it's probably
because there's just no good data out
there I mean it's not like you know I'm
trying to ignore it's just like we don't
know and so but just in the last few
years have been an explosion of research
into in am in fasting water-only fast
thing you know five to 20
five five time restrictive feeding all
these and so tremendous literature
what's interesting about the
intermittent fasting literature well so
in terms of investing no benefit in
terms of compliance or lean mass
conservation or weight loss compared to
continuous caloric restriction and the
longest largest studies debate shows
increasing cholesterol for people that
have the same claw restriction doing
alternate a modified fasting and so I
would encourage people not to do it or
at least check cholesterol checked but
the time restrictive feeding where you
try to narrow your eating window to
twelve hours or less and so your fasting
at least half the day what was that's
this is one of the research areas where
there was diametrically opposed some
studies so it's great for you other
studies so it's terrible for you has all
these negative metabolic consequences
and so it was my job to like what is
going on here and it turns out it's
timing early versus late so when do you
break the fast so your window right so
if your window is late you get the
negative biological consequence of
eating at night I'm and and and shifting
your calories towards later in the day
and so people that skip breakfast I had
these negative metabolic effects of
timer Street feeding whereas people that
did early time restrictive feeding not
only got the Bennett the carnal
biological benefits of shifting their
calories towards the beginning of the
day they also got the time restricted
feeding benefits and so that is really
the I'm that that that's that's one of
the things in the book that actually
changed the way my family eats yeah you
just rocked me with that because I do it
where I eat at night if you're good I
don't eat there if you miss any meal it
should be it should be you supper enough
breakfast right breakfast is called
break fast for a reason yeah I mean wow
yeah I mean and and and that actually
may be one of the reason that the seven
day Adventists vegetarians live the
longest living population in the world
right okinawa japanese was at number two
and they're done they now they're eating
KFC
there's really only one blue zone that
continues to this day it's in Loma Linda
California these seventh-day Adventists
longest-living formally stop study
population in the world but me one of
the reasons may be because they practice
this early time restrictive eating often
skipping supper of the the teachings of
the church are you know like two meals a
day and you know make lunch the biggest
meal a day um it hasn't been put to the
test but given all this a short term
data yeah this is very interesting maybe
oh no that'll be the next book how not
to age I'll look deep into that is it is
that the nature is starting January 25
one that'll be out December 22 what's
the book after that um I think it's
gonna be a lot to die from cancer for
cancer survivors unfortunately you know
the advice people with cancer diagnosis
get to see whatever you want or just
keep weight on or whatever terrible
advice I mean now we actually have some
decent data on cancer survival not just
prevent I mean so how not to die how to
prevent cancer what if you already have
cancer what can we do to slow down stop
or burst so that'll that'll pray next
and then but I'm gonna do one a mental
health how not to age though that's a
that's a good one I just had David
Sinclair in here the other day great I
got Dan Buettner coming back here
tomorrow
[Music]
aging stuff that's super interesting I
mean I think the work that David is
doing obviously that's in the genetic
field it's not nutrition per se but I
think there's so much emerging science
that's happening right there it's pretty
fast you know in fact there was this one
seminal paper that really inspired me to
write the whole book and that was
basically the Big Pharma got together
the top researchers in the world flew
them to the some luxury resort somewhere
and so Sinclair was there and long ago
on everybody who's anyone in the field
got paid enough money to all come
together to list the most potentially
the the the most druggable longevity
pathways in the body like we wanted to
make a you know a longevity drug how
would we do it right it said they all
sat down they came up with these five
biochemical pathways for longevity and I
looked at this I said wait a second
every single one of these we can modify
would diet you know sort of talk about
like mTOR
igf-1 and all the wait a second think we
could all do that you know so I was like
all this like Burt that's the whole book
one chapter on each we can yeah I'm so
I'm really said Wow yeah very cool
so I imagine you probably get this from
time to time dr. Greger love the new
book but I got to tell you I've been on
the keto diet I've lost all this weight
I feel good or I'm on the carnivore diet
I'm on this diet I'm on that diet so you
know like you can't tell me that your
way is better than my way right and I
mean I can say let's see your lab work
or let me see your arteries let me see
your calcium score let me see I mean you
know I just mean anything that's the
that's a sort of common retort from the
low carb carnivore camp that these the
blood work is misleading because it
doesn't necessarily mean what it says ah
well I mean if you have science to
support that but that's not what I mean
the science shows I mean I mean so you
know there's you know the presidential
advisory from the American Heart
Association came out you know for it to
because of these crazy myths out there
that they have to write these papers
saying yes that's a fight it's bad for
you yes coconut oil is bad for you and I
mean and and yes LDLs is leaning
predictor of our disease I mean you know
I mean things that have been settled
science for decades but in the Internet
age of flat earthers we have to come out
and explicitly explicitly say right and
so I mean yeah so and and and we don't
just have a short term biomarkers we
have you know large populations people
who fall diets even even trending in
that direction living significally
shorter lives it is interesting that the
carnivore diet has has caught the
attention of so many people and seems to
be like a like a trending thing right
now it's like it's like it's like if
internet troll were a diet it would be
please just like that right but I mean
look you can imagine someone with food
intolerance whether it's celiac disease
or anything the ultimate determination
right and so people go on elimination
diets I mean typically put someone on
like you know water sweet potatoes and
tapioca like three things no one's
allergic to and then all of a sudden
their joints feel better they more
energy all of a sudden their chronic
indigestion goes away okay and then you
add back what was it what was it about
your diet that you know was causing a
problem and so them it's the same thing
I mean you're just basically you know
excluding and so if you did have some
kind of intolerance well then you know
but obviously then you'd want to add
healthy foods back into your diet to
find out what it is and so you can I've
one of the things that I've been
contending with in the last couple years
I mean I've been plant-based for 13
years now is the fact that now there is
this proliferation of amazing taste
tasting plant-based analogues to every
food imaginable right and it all tastes
great and I'll find myself indulging in
that a little bit more than I should and
kind of you know selling the lie to
myself like oh it's it's plant-based
it's cool you know and knowing of course
like isn't the healthiest thing you know
and then I follow that up with with
another kind of layer of denial which is
that because I'm an athlete that I can
kind of outrun it you know I can burn it
on and as long as I'm trim and I feel
good that I'm not I'm not necessarily
paying the same toll than somebody else
is and I know that's not true and and so
there's always like yeah I'm plant-based
but I can I can certainly iterate and
evolve you know to do better than I'm
doing
yeah ya know and that ain't bright it's
the process and it's harder I mean but I
mean what I see you know when I see an
ad from Burger King bragging that it's
1% Wofford 0% beef they're bragging that
there's no beef in their new burger I
mean that just speaks to me to the
tremendous surge in interest and plump I
see of course
I don't magic be right so but when I say
right but nutritionally right if you
look at these things often more sodium
use the coconut oil base oh man as much
more saturated fat even sometimes so
these are right not healthy foods step
in the right direction step
in stone foods I like them you know um
you know not everyone could go you know
kale quinoa overnight but transition
foods to get people in direction of
eating healthier so I see that as a
tremendously kind of optimistic social
phenomenon but my concern is that people
will stop there people will you just
kind of switch over their milk shakes
their cheese burgers and milkshakes and
then stall there and not capture the
full benefits of
Blimpie's um yeah it's never been easier
to to Evie you can go you can get your
you can go to Burger King and get fries
and a burger and you can then go get
coconut ice cream and knock yourself out
and then wonder how come I'm not losing
weight fatter yeah yeah I just yeah I
moved to Philly recently there are
multiple all vegan doughnut shops like
Oh which all vegan doughnut shop do you
want to go you know I mean I mean that's
right and so right I mean you can be you
can have a terrible terrible vegan diet
I know that if I'm eating whole food
plant-based and I'm adhering to that
pretty strictly that I don't really have
to like the idea of needing to diet it
just doesn't it just I don't have to
worry about it right so how need you to
die how not I know that's tricky right
how to diet not as Yoda would say would
have retitled it so knowing that then it
is now it is how not to diet and yet it
is a program that extends beyond just
eat these foods like you have these
strategies and things to kind of
accelerate that aspect of it right and
because I wanted to I mean with so much
kind of nutritional noise and nonsense
out there I just wanted there to finally
be not only an evidence-based diet book
but you know I said thousands of studies
digging up every possible you know tip
trick tweet technique proven to
accelerate loss of body fat to give
people at every possible advantage and
kind of you know build them optimal
weight loss solutions from the ground up
basically my criteria is if I mean if
it's been proven to cause weight loss
and it's not I mean they're ahead of low
bar but like I don't have a chapter on
which cigarettes are
best to smoke away and we know nicotine
is I mean a proven you know but so I say
look we can eat nicotine containing
foods and maybe get some benefits but um
and there was some some things actually
cut out like there was a licorice root
chapter I took out because the
therapeutic index of you could get too
much licorice really easily and hurt
yourself but there were some things
there was some base level of safety but
beyond that if a car's weight loss in a
randomized control trial it's in the
book and I want to give people every
possible kind of advantage since that's
our came this kind of twenty one tweaks
thing to add on to their daily dozen now
they've got like 40 check marks every
day you know if you really wanted to go
all out so if somebody comes to you and
says listen I'm fifty sixty pounds
overweight I got a I got a drop this
weight my life hangs in the balance like
how do you kickstart that person like
walk me through like if you had you know
five or ten minutes to speak to this
person how do you kind of get them
sorted in on their way yeah so get them
the right information right I mean so
yeah so you know I could show them the
app doctor various daily dozen free app
obviously everything I do everything I
produce is available free um and then
you know tell them about something like
21-day kickstart program from PCRM or a
physician I mean for Responsible
medicine first of every month totally
free bunch of different languages
hundreds of thousands people have done
it you do is kind of social media group
together and you know you get daily
advice and tips and things like that
again just to stick with it long enough
so you can see the benefits yourself and
then it's no longer some doctor wagging
their finger at you'll be have that
internal motivation to stick with it cuz
you feel so much better digestion better
your sleeps better your Energy's better
oh and you're losing weight and you know
without writing about it what are some
of the crazier turnaround stories that
you've heard or experienced oh well I
mean the most exciting things is
diseases for which there's nothing in
the literature that suggested it's
possible so people come to me and say
I've Hashimoto's thyroiditis
hypothyroidism and I tell them you're
gonna be on thyroid hormone replacement
rest your life your thyroids all scarred
up it's over and we can help prevent it
but you know and they say no no I had it
I have diagnosed I was on this for years
and then I went
bass and all the sudden I'm off my
thyroid medication here's my TSH is my
lab values and I tell them your doctor
has to write you up as a case study I
want to see this publish and I'll do a
video about it I mean so you know
someone comes to me with ankylosing
spondylitis and one of these you know
horrible inflammatory autoimmune
diseases I'm like look we have great
data on Crohn's and multiple sclerosis
and yeah and and all sort of kleiss and
other similar rheumatoid arthritis up
rised it helps with your disease but it
hasn't been anything published yet and
so quick we gotta get you we got we have
to you know it doesn't exist in the
scientific world and less is published
in peer-reviewed scientific literature
and so I encourage them to get it out
there and actually there was just a case
series and ankylosing spondylitis I'm
excited to say but I mean those I mean
you expect that you you I'd no longer
have diabetes and heart disease I mean
all these things and you know teary-eyed
and you know I mean it's you know
they're out of their wheelchair they're
walking again it's they have their lives
back and have a future again that you
know old that that's why I've been
seeing for years but what some of these
new you know where someone says you know
I have some you know some disease I have
to look up I mean help with that too he
said wait a second it's a little snake
oil ii panacea right I mean that's yet
that's a red flag when someone says my
thing can help with XY and Z but you
realize look we're talking about a diet
that improves arterial health every
single one of our organs needs blood
flow to get rid of waste products get
oxygen nutrients and so the no wonder
that a heart healthy diet is a brain
healthy diet is a liver healthy diet is
a kidney healthy diet right and a
plant-based diet is a whole food
plant-based diet is basically synonymous
with an anti-inflammatory diet and since
inflammation plays roles so many chronic
diseases no wanderin anti-inflammatory
diet is gonna help kind of across the
board with all these things and so I
mean there's these kind of underlying
you know mechanisms by which you can
imagine and look even if someone will
ask me what does it work for a disease
you know Z that you know and I say well
I don't know bud healthy guy can only
help right I mean look and probably
people with disease D Z prop
we still die of heart disease number one
right so forget for example breast
cancer postmenopausal breast cancer
number one killer of women with older
women with breast cancer heart disease
still kills them more than breast cancer
and so whether or not a hopeful blemish
that reverses breast cancer you're still
you were still more likely in that
emergency and we know we can reverse
heart disease so of course everyone with
breast cancer of course everyone should
be on this healthy diet and then if
there's side benefits well then great I
mean you know as we see with prostate
cancer and some other conditions well
when you look at yeah like what you like
what you said I mean what's killing
people heart disease stroke obesity you
know in terms of brain health
alzheimer's is exploding right now and
to the extent that you're eating in a
way that's improving arterial function
and reducing inflammation right the
downstream domino impact of that you
know has all kinds of positive
consequences even if it doesn't help it
helps doesn't help that particular thing
it's like that meme of what if it turned
out that that that global warming is a
hoax we just improve the planet for no
reason I mean like well just stopping
smoking help this disease I don't know
but it's probably a good idea to stop
smoking right I mean it's just a minute
just gonna what is a day in your
personal life with food like how do you
make it work well on the right well
again no travelers yeah how do you deal
with the airports and all of it yeah
Airport food courts yeah well look it's
getting easier now you can get like
brown rice in an airport I mean that's
great like these like you know fast
casual places like you know things you
never expect to see before and look
there's you know I've grown better you
know if I can you know land someplace
and find Whole Foods and have a hot bar
and grab some food and you know first
few days I have snacks and then slowly
it's all done you know what I've been
doing recently is I we tell the
organizers you gotta bring me food
mm-hmm you know I mean there's only so
many Mike Reider there's only so many
sweet potatoes like he's greater I
played with the crazy Ryder van Halen
not like no green M&Ms no M&Ms period
it's all right um and so right and so
look i you know i need to I yeah and
typically I don't even have time even if
I could I mean right even if there's
healthy food around here I am Southern
California I can get healthy food but I
don't have time I mean it's just and on
the rare days here at home
oh now then once I have control over my
how excited you and know that's a
beautiful thing all right well I mean I
just yeah this is my first day of this
this few weeks tint uh-huh and so I'm
feeling the the leaving home thing it
was hard to get up this morning but um
yeah then I can eat this beautiful diet
oh my and it's like it so much it's like
a it's like a it's like a game like how
healthy can I get I mean it's really and
and you know what helped so I do love
food delivery like Whole Foods delivery
and then then you're not even tempted to
buy junk because it's not in front of
you Grammy and so it's like everything I
eat
so my house just as healthy food and so
if you get hungry enough you're gonna
eat an apple right I mean there's
nothing up you will eventually eat that
Apple right and so with only healthy
stuff you know I can I can build up my
healthy immune system always making a
healthy choice the the most convenient
right oh yeah I could go out and you
know in the Philadelphia winter and bike
someplace to get something to bike to
the donut shop but so much easier when I
have a fridge full of yummy food and do
you prepare stuff ahead of time I do a
lot of batch cooking yeah yeah yeah
particularly now I'm doing a lot of this
this prebiotic mix I talked about my
winner in studying the improving your
microbiome for the new big microbiome
chapter in the in the diet book and just
learning how again how important
microbiome is and where are the most
concentrated source of prebiotics and so
I did I discovered sorghum for the first
time discovered all these weird millets
that I had no idea that have poorly
digested starch and so they are fed to
animals but poorly digested starch is
exactly what we want because it's for
the digested in our small intestine
makes it down to our lower intestine
where our good gut bugs can have a
bounty of prebiotics and then has all
those knock-on benefits and so that's
the kind of thing where I just instant
pot a huge amount and just you know
Tupperware in the fridge and you know
take out one every day since it's over
in you know so I always have I always
have my intact grains and a whole bunch
of wonderful black lentils and then it's
a matter of just getting greens in the
house what else did you learn about the
gut that gut biome and in prepping for
this what's neat is now we have this
interventional trust so we've always
known you you can so flashback a few
years ago it was a black hole almost no
pun intended where because most gut bugs
are actually own culture Bowl in
laboratory conditions like we can't grow
them outside of look human colon we
don't know what that gasps oh well you
don't know and so it we likely had no
idea what's going on there until we had
genetic fingerprinting techniques and
also and for the first time we'd be like
oh okay we can actually track people's
microbiome over time compare people's
different microbiome and we can
correlate diseases with with different
bugs in our gut and change people's
diets change the microbiome see the
beneficial or adverse effects but that's
the problem if you improve someone's
diet all of a sudden you give people
lots of whole grains and legumes beans
split peas chickpeas and lentils
lots of prebiotics they get these
beneficial changes in their microbiome
and also and they have amazing health
benefits uh yeah but you just fed them a
whole bunch of healthy food how do we
know microbiome has anything to do with
it
that's where fecal transplants come
along right and we can prove it's the
microbiome because we can take those gut
buffs and put it into somebody who's
continuously the crappy diet and see if
we can get those same metabolic benefits
and that's what we're saying so we're
seeing yeah so you know someone gets a
fecal transplant for someone who's
overweight also and they start packing
on pounds eating the same food or
there's that's crazy mental health
changes all sorts of crazy things um and
now we can prove it's the gut bug now
what happens is of course it's temporary
because right you you infuse the gut
bugs but then you keep starving them by
not eating any fiber and then they die
away but you see initially those same
benefits of course you've got to feed
those go
they're gonna die off but but so so what
went from a from a correlation science
now we have a causation science and it's
just fascinating that we can transfer
the benefits of healthy diets so so I
mean so the the black market rich role
stool you could I mean you know the the
the I mean yeah start selling that [ __ ]
exactly who wouldn't it is it is
fascinating I mean there's links to
cravings as well like nature owns a gut
flora impacts the foods that you crave a
yeah yeah and it also I think is is
because it's so complex that it's right
for confusion and people kind of making
claims about what you should and you
shouldn't do that we don't necessarily
have the ability to really back up at
this point particularly this kind of
personalized nutrition like people all
the time are sending me things my I sent
my stool sample in to this company and
gave me back a thing and said I should
be eating this and I shouldn't be eating
this we don't have that concern you
Larry does not same thing with the DNA
testing right people that get back there
their genome and say oh well I know I'm
whatever I shouldn't be eating the x y&z
we don't have that kind of but is it
true we should be eating fermented foods
and we should be eating you know
nutritionally a variety of nutritionally
dense foods to be kind of seeding that
that gut flora with a diversity of
bacteria so it's the three rights
prebiotics probiotics and polyphenols
which of these kind of tend to be
brightly colored pigments in fruits and
vegetables these are kind of the three
are the three things that benefit a good
microbiome and you can use all three of
them or just two of them I mean the
problem with probiotics is you take them
and then they just die off you don't
continue to eat healthy and so if you
just have like antibiotic associated
diarrhea or something you wipe out you
go got bugs then I see a therapeutic
role of something like probiotics but
otherwise taking probiotics it's useless
because they'll just die off if you put
them in the same environment that didn't
grow good gut bugs in the first place
putting in some good acidophilus and
they're just gonna die off because
you're not feeding the acidophilus cuz
good gut bugs are by definition fiber
feeders resistant starch eaters these
are I mean that's
then that's what makes good gut bugs
grow and so what we really need is we
just need to feed our good gut bugs
prebiotics and people who are like oh I
eat so many fruits and vegetables but
must realize fruits and vegetables or
almost all water like you know fruits or
like 80 percent water or somewhere where
specials 90 95 percent water their water
and vegetable form not actually a lot of
fiber you can actually have a pretty
deficient fiber deficient diet if you're
not including whole grains and legumes
some of these drier foods into your
daily diet wow that's good to know
alright cuz I just thought well as long
as I'm eating a lot of high-fiber foods
like I'm basically taking care of my
prebiotic needs all right but there is
actually not so the fruits and
vegetables are not high they're high
fiber foods compared to what 99% of the
population eats but um if you're really
trying to build you know 70 grams a day
you know 80 grams a day or like 120
grams which is how we probably evolved
you know based on human cop the lights
you know fossilized feces then I mean if
you and you do the math you people don't
even close so you know Ornish you know
really healthy you know hopeful
plant-based diet and you gotta like 60
which is you know average is about 15
recommended minimum is about 30 and so
getting 60 but I mean that's and that's
a remarkably healthy diet to shoot up
there and then these population studies
where they have know essentially no
heart disease no diabetes no breast
cancer no you know like sub-saharan
Africa half century ago they were
getting you know the the triple digit
fiber construction every day and so part
of that benefit may actually have been
the microbiome and that was the benefit
of the fiber as opposed to you know drop
a one's cholesterol or something right
more will be revealed though I think
there's there's there's got to be like
lots of crazy studies being performed
right now know and so there there are
vegan fecal transplant studies what can
we you give someone you know you know
you know they do it through tubes they
do it to capsules I you know you just
don't want to burp after that you know
that kind of thing do you know Robin
shut can dr. Robin shuck can
dc-dc physician who specializes in the
microbiome and she was that she was on
the show a long time ago but she was
predicting not only fecal transplants
becoming like a booming business but
actual spas like high-end spas where you
could go and have your you know your
artisanal I want them to eat for the
week before you show up exactly right
that's great well let's let's shift
gears I want to talk about sitting for a
minute you did some interesting stuff
here on the book of around that I know
you're we're sitting at sitting is
unless you're on an airplane or in a car
yeah yeah I'm staying yeah stuck my butt
all day in a plane typically um but yeah
so I mean I there's this myth that
sitting some new smoking not by any
stretch of imagination at least ten
times more deadly to smoke than to sit
but prolonged sitting define typically
over six hours a day is associated with
increased mortality even if you then go
out to the gym and work out hard for an
hour a day after work and so it does I
mean that helps but doesn't completely
counterbalance the fact that you're
sitting all day and we think a lot of
that has to do with the venous stasis
they they the quack you bill coagula
bility of your blood the fact that
you're not actually having movement of
blood from your veins in your lower legs
effects into thela function and effects
kind of you're kind of a systemic
arterial tree but even something like
you know bobbing your knee up and down
has been shown to completely eliminate
this effect that's wild um and so in the
end they have someone just Bob one knee
up and down versus the other and you can
measure the differences and what's going
on their legs and that is what's
correlated with this increased you know
cardiovascular disease morbidity
mortality so there's a way so even if
your truck driver or even if you're
stuck inside all day send down there are
things you can do and so yeah there's
all sorts of I go through all the the
various different like little bars and
things they can put on your desk and
which ones work which ones are just fad
and so there are ways you can kind of
mouse effect but or you
you know do standing desks walking desk
I love getting back to my walking desk I
dicted to the thing wasn't there a study
that you looked at where they put people
on basically you know a a standardized
amount of calories every day and said
you can exercise this much and there was
a difference in between you know some of
them lost weight some of them didn't and
it came down to how much they were
sitting and then there was this
realization that there are certain
people that are walking around all the
time he's kind of casually throughout
the day and they were having amazing
benefits that the people who were just
eating the same and working out the same
who were sitting more weren't able to
realize these neat benefits read these
non-exercise through money so so what
what they so what they realized is that
we typically you know this whole
calories in calories out and you ask
people what matters and people actually
either say they're the same or calories
out matters more and that's completely
not true we have almost total control
over calories in fact we could eat
nothing although can calories out
typical exercise like casual exerciser
it's only like 5% of calories out most
of our calories out are our energy
intensive brains most wild animals
movement is their number-one calories
out for us it's our brains we could lie
down in bed chained to a bed all day
still burn over a thousand calories the
most of the and so that's why it's it's
so hard to outrun a bad diet because you
know even a moderately exercise
moderately obese person moderately
intensely exercising for an hour burns
350 calories I mean most snacks drinks
processed foods have like 70 Cal are
consumed it's 70 calories a minute so
five minutes eating just wiped out a
whole hour of exercise that's why it's
so difficult but what they learned is
because and so there's a there's a you
know like a 60 percent slice that's just
like you know your basal metabolic you
know activity keeping your breathing
your heart pumping your brain going and
then there's a small sliver unless
you're a mountain climber an Army Ranger
something really doing intense exercise
you just have a small fraction of
voluntary says but then there's this non
exercise thermogenesis which is
fidgeting which is just moving
walking around you know standing rather
than sitting I think so the now we have
these accelerometers we can put on
people and so really revolutionized our
understanding of where these calories
are going and why you put people on the
same kind of same calorie diet of the
same enforced exercise schedule and some
people lose vastly more amounts of
weight than others and most of that had
to do it's not like some people just you
know had metabolic slowing or there's
some biochemical thing going on know is
the amount of the of this this this
cannon on you know you know typical kind
of exercise you know where you're
sending out a half an hour to do any
kind of exercise it was just that
they're just moving around more during
the day and so how can we enforce that
well being at a standing desk you have
postural muscles otherwise you'd
collapse to your floor you know anything
you can do to get you to just move
yourself more and you know bouncing your
knees that kind of stuff I mean that
dovetails pretty perfectly with the Blue
Zones findings right that these people
that live so long and live so healthy
are people that are just kind of in
constant low-grade motion throughout the
day right they're not going to the gym
right now because their whole life it's
just not we were built to move and so
you know and so I mean that's what some
of that sipping data suggests what about
the person who has struggled to lose
weight their whole life and no matter
what they do they just continue to gain
or they can't you know they stay at a
certain point is there is there validity
to this being hormonal or an endocrine
problem you know here people say like oh
it's my genetic makeup or you know I
just have a slow metabolism right so
there are some conditions so for example
hypothyroidism meaning where does slow
down your metabolism by about fifteen
percent and indeed it's just it's harder
for them to lose weight but there's no
such thing as someone who's basically
obesity resistant there used to be there
are people claim no matter what even if
I don't need anything I gain weight or
don't lose weight and so scientists lock
them in a lab and when you do that
everybody everybody everybody with has
never been a single published case
they lose weight in fact exactly as they
should in terms of body fat some of them
and this is where this comes from
start retaining water such that they
lose no weight after not eating for four
days um so the bathroom scale says they
haven't lost a pound but if you actually
do CT scans DEXA scans actually see
what's going on so their body they're
losing body fat exactly as predicted but
they're retaining all this water and
then finally when that diuresis happens
all of a sudden they plunge down and
match exactly on to the curve but it can
take days for you to reach that so you
can imagine people who are like I'm
starving myself for literally days not
losing a pound there's something wrong
with me no you are actually losing body
fat every single day it's just your
scale doesn't tell you the you know the
the what compartments you're losing that
weight from wow that's interesting
because I feel like that that does come
up quite a bit people you know will say
just you know I there's something
different about my genetic makeup that
makes me immune from these positive
experiences that other people have so
they just have to get enough time yeah
one of the things that I hear quite
frequently is rich you know I've been
listening to you I read your book blah
blah whatever I saw the movies
I went plant-based for a while and now
I'm you know I'm pretty much there but I
went back to some fish and a little bit
of you know a little bit of meat here
and there so I'm kind of 90% in your
direction like is that good like it how
do you how does this how does the
evidence in the science break down in
terms of somebody who's predominantly
plant-based I guess the word plant-based
I mean how do you define that if you're
plant-based it doesn't mean your your
plant perfect or your right plant a
hundred percent what is the difference
between somebody who is you know
adhering to you know your optimal
protocol versus the person who is
indulging in a little bit of meat and
dairy products on the side I think the
body has remarkable ability to bounce
back from insults in fact that's what
this kind of this heart disease reversal
data shows is that you can have you can
eat a lifetime of this horrible food and
then even when the average age is like
in the 60s some of these reversal
studies and even after a lifetime
you can clean off there's the body was
just waiting for you to stop you know
attacking your arteries with these foods
and you could rapidly
I'm reversal and you get more reversal
the more compliance you get but but
these the compliance wasn't perfect in
most of these studies and so people were
eating those kind of ninety percent type
diets and seeing the remarkable benefits
you know it's like there's no study in
the world that suggests someone with
who's like a social smoker picks up a
few cigarettes at a party once a year is
gonna have any greater you know lung
cancer risk than someone who doesn't
smoke at all of course we tell people
don't smoke at all because we're afraid
this kind of kind of you know lead down
that path and some people are easier or
ironically more compliant with strict
rules black and white rules so if you're
like there's no cheese in the house
versus a little cheese and I'm just
gonna have a little bit the concern I
think with a lot of these plant-based
physicians who are like absolutely
strict zero you know we don't want you
to eat any of this it's not that they
think it's not that the science supports
we need that level of compliance to get
the benefits but the concern is you
won't is that you'll slip back down to
your old guys okay so it's a
psychological you know you know it's
easier for for for an alcoholic to
complete each other yeah this yeah trust
me I mean a couple observations on that
I mean I certainly fall into that camp
like I have to have ardent strict rules
around this stuff because if I you know
partake a little bit that just opens the
door for more like I just know myself
well enough to know like if if I could
have a little bit of cheese here and
here and there that I could maintain
that for a little while but six months
later they're they're probably be a lot
more cheese happening like that would be
that would be the harm it wouldn't be
that cheese ones right that wouldn't be
that it's that it triggers it it
basically keeps that craving alive right
rather than allowing me to transcendent
and it doesn't allow your tastebuds to
adapt right I mean so I mean we our
taste buds have been so deaded by this
deadened by the hyper salty hyper sweet
hyper fatty foods such that natural
foods don't taste any good
and so then you feel like some kind of
aesthetic monk where you just eating it
but give it a few weeks and all of a
sudden you know the soup salt had to
taste weeks ago we have these great
studies so it's actually to salt you
prefer lower salts
and the same thing happens with you no
but look the rapist peach in the world
tastes sour after bowl of Froot Loops
like in natural food but all of a sudden
you get to a point where if you start if
you get rid of all that crap then all of
a sudden you know corn on the cob no
butter no salt tastes delicious like
natural healthy whole food then you get
the best of both worlds wait a second
tastes delicious and you get to live
longer that's what plant-based eating is
all about but you may never get there if
you you know well I'll have a little
cheese here a little cheese there you
maintain that you can't like that yeah
except then and then then okay I'm gonna
be good eat that salad and this how it
doesn't taste like cardboard because you
know it doesn't have the same kind of
yeah right I I know that to be true
because I've experienced that in my life
but I think people hearing that think
it's [ __ ] like they're like they
can't believe they can't believe that
that's true they're like that sounds
great but there's no way yeah I have
about this is that I don't think people
are very good objective they're not
objective about about what they're truly
doing like when they say I having a
little bit of this or I have a moderate
amount of this I think their their
perception of that moderation is is
generally in my experience completely
out of whack no in fact there's a great
study that I talked about in the new
book where and and this is the reason
why moderation why food industry loves
moderation they asked people what they
thought a moderate amount of chocolate
would be moderate amount of you know
process meet modern mounted they go
through all these foods right and what
was the definition of moderate exactly
how much they themselves were eating no
matter how much they're eating that was
defined as moderate based on their own
intake they were even in chocolate bar
every day that's moderate intake and so
so when the food industry says
everything in moderation that's pathetic
that's basically giving people license
to do exactly what they were doing
before because they all everyone thinks
that they're eating moderate amounts of
bad food Ronny's and it goes back to the
psychology of all of this it really
isn't about the information it's about
it's about people's emotional you know
baggage around all of this stuff that
and I really think that that is the
biggest barrier like when somebody says
I can't lose weight or what there's
there's a whole you know package there
that needs to be you know really
deconstructed in order to get that
person you know acclimated towards a new
way of living and eating and I have a
chapter in the book talking about those
psychological we have these glitches
right so I talked about like in
psychology delivery so they called -
what the hell effect that's the ue1
cooking they eat the whole bag because I
already screwed up but which makes
absolutely no sense just take step back
waiting so I I made one step away from
what my planned so I'm just gonna go all
if that makes absolutely no sense in
fact you eat that one then you
definitely shouldn't eat the whole but
but our psychology goes in the absolute
wrong direction and the same thing then
there's a the flipside is making
progress towards a goal actually gives
people license though you know so losing
weight one week um is correlated with
gaining weight the next way right you're
you but just the understanding of that
knowing that that's a glitch um that the
hope is that you can catch yourself huh
right and so you know I find myself you
know after some for our book signing you
know the you know jet lag to heck you
know staring at whatever goodies are in
my hotel minibar right and have this my
first way just like I deserve this like
oh my god Ben what I went through today
but then I really I just what the hell
but you're alright I just you know I
just I I just I I the self licensing and
I say no what I deserve of course
mmm-hmm is to be healthy so yeah I think
I think momentum is underrated too once
people get a little practice with this
and they're starting to see even the
smallest amount of result positive
result then it really like enforces you
know that drive to keep going and it's
almost like an insurance policy or a
barrier against those kind of slips and
I'm something mystical about that and in
that does argue towards the more if
you're gonna try it go all in as opposed
to the 8090 percent right well if you're
gonna try it like a free sample right
that's what I used to tell my patients
right right like if you look you can eat
anything for a few weeks you mean
nothing for viewings I mean let's just
let's try it let's go all in just you
know and because people can't stomach
the thought of I'm never going to need
another pepperoni pizza rest of my life
like this is unthinkable
but like no no just a couple weeks then
we can go right back to even whatever
you want you know just give it a try I'm
in the but but the hope is that they go
all-in they start to feel the benefits
right so they're they're less painful
periods they're they're chronic
migraines whatever whatever it is such
that then have that internal motivation
even if they don't take advantage and
they do slip back to their old ways they
know at least in the back of their mind
they know how good they could feel at
any time if they just moved in that
direction but you don't know how good
you're gonna feel to give it a try what
changes would you make to our system of
healthcare if you were in charge I mean
you know listen nobody goes into
medicine to you know just be a vehicle
for for diagnosis and prescription you
know but the system is set up to create
a dynamic that forces medical
practitioners into this kind of practice
that you know isn't really necessarily I
would imagine what they thought they
were signing up for yeah I mean it's
really the I mean in fact if you look at
mental health statistics of practices
these days particularly in the United
States this is not what we kind of
signed up for because most of what comes
in our door about 80 percent in primary
care are these chronic diseases for
which we have very little to offer our
patients then kind of traditional
medical model right we can slow down the
rate at which you go blind or which you
lose your kidney function we can slow
down the rate at which you know your
arteries clogged off by you know
prescribing these drugs and only have a
little time so we give these
prescriptions but instead of giving
fully informed consent that well here's
your other options that I don't have
time to tell you about and are may work
better and less side effects but I mean
the the system is set up to kind of
reward bad behavior the most profitable
doctor visit in North America is a blood
pressure check doctors love it everybody
loves it they're being billed for it
they come in you're on a blood pressure
medication they come in every and then
you tweak the drug a little bit and then
come back it's the easiest you know is
you fit it in a few minutes you get to
Bill for it and in it's the most common
primary care visit and for a condition
that need not happen at all
this is lifestyle disease high blood
pressures lifestyle disease but that
entire sector of the field would be gone
both big farm
and and big medicine I mean no one
benefits from people eating healthier I
mean if you go down the list like the
junk food industry the we name one
industry that would that would benefit
from people eating healthier and you say
well what about the health insurance
industry don't they benefit from people
because they have to pay for it all no
they get a slice of the pie and the
bigger the pie the bigger the slice I
mean that you know when I when I get to
talk to these you know healthcare
executives of these conferences first of
all they'll say well you know they're
only gonna be on my insurance for a few
years and I switches people switched
insurance so frequently why am I gonna
prevent their diabetes and have some
other company benefit from my preventing
their diabetes and it's the pie I mean
it's just so expensive and and they they
get their cut and the more expensive it
is the bigger the cut and it's just the
whole system is rigged kind of against
us
you know the CEOs of junk food companies
aren't sitting around trying to think of
way creative ways to contribute to the
childhood obesity epidemic they just
need to make money for the shareholders
how do you do that you don't do that
selling something that goes bad like
produce that you can't brand you can't
making you want a snack cake that sits
on the Shelf right I mean I mean the
system is just set up to to you know
reward these behaviors that make people
sick yeah so how do we change the
incentive ization so that we get more
Robert Oz belts and Michelle McCracken's
who are who you know have created
practices where they have follow up an
accountability and they're they're you
know providing that kind of extra level
of care to help people make these
lifestyle shifts like there has to be an
economic structure that that that you
know makes it attractive for young
doctors to enter into this yes so I mean
it's a reimbursement I mean that's a you
know Dean Ornish had this famous quote
saying that you know he thought was the
research but knows all about reimbursed
me you know so he proved back in
nineteen ninety right decades ago you
could reverse heart disease number-one
killer and you know is you know hundreds
of thousands people continue to die
every year needlessly it because it's
not the the lifestyle purchase isn't
reimbursed and so yes some people can
fight against the the buck the trend and
find creative ways to like these shared
medical visits where
can bill insurance you this actually no
technical maximum for the number of
people you can get you can get 30 people
in Rome and you bill insurance for each
of those 30 people and give the same
little speech that you give for a group
diabetics or a group of people with
obesity and so that's one of the kind of
ways that within the system I'm doctor
to be able to to get reimbursed but yeah
I mean it we just need to change the
incentives like why do do US taxpayer
subsidized by the billions the the sugar
industry the corn syrup industry the the
make cheap livestock feed $4 man your
burgers why why are we paying a quarter
billion dollars to the sorghum industry
I'm buying some sorghum now because I
love it but I didn't even know about it
a few months ago right no it's all fed
to livestock uh-huh and so I mean now
you can argue we shouldn't be subset
that government should be subsidizing
the foods out but if you're going to
subsidize this how about subsidizing
fruits and vegetables making them
cheaper even free to em because then
they'll have also said knock-on benefits
in terms of lower costs across the board
yeah taking those subsidies and
channeling them into improving health
care or creating those incentives what's
the the controversy is so who's gonna
pay for health care not what the
fundamental health care is going to be
right
I think Ornish did create a reimbursable
program absolutely paid right pay for
reimbursed by Medicare there's two
programs now him and Pritikin um and and
and I speak at hospital I speak at
Ornish programs across the country
that's often my in into a medical system
to kind of promote the program saying
that this option exists yeah speaking of
Pritikin Pritikin you know your your
entry point to this whole thing begins
with Pritikin yeah yeah amazing right
and not a doctor right people always
think doc britain now he's an engineer
came from the outside diagnosed with
with serious heart disease in his early
40s and was and was basically told the
you go home and die there's nothing we
can do about it I'm back then we didn't
have drugs for I mean couldn't even put
anybody on anything and people just were
first and you die heart disease
reversible no but then he looked around
the world found these popular you use a
data guy you just went and so there's
population of the world that don't
suffer from epidemic heart disease like
it's unknown people just don't have
heart
in rural China sub-saharan Africa wait a
sec what was it about these populations
he figured oh maybe it's cholesterol and
started experimenting around how we can
lower people cholesterol came
plant-based diet and reversed you know
heart disease by the thousands bought
back then we didn't have angiography we
didn't have this ability to visualize
inside what the artists were looking
like and so it's a clinical diagnosis
that angina they could they had such bad
heart disease it couldn't walk up the
steps but you just had to trust that the
patient had engine and all of a sudden
they go on a plant-based diet and all of
a sudden they're they're running
marathons and the response the medical
community's well you never had heart
disease first place if you had heart
disease you wouldn't be running
marathons well but it's because it was
simple but all of a sudden what Orange
brought to the table is we could prove
with something called quantitative
angiography oh we can actually see the
arteries open up get bigger improved
blood flow reversal proof in black and
white pups of some of those prestigious
medical journals in the world and but
one of those people that Pritikin
reverse their heart disease was francis
gregor my grandmother who you know the
in a wheelchair after so many bypass
surgeries basically run on the plumbing
and there she was and saw about Pritikin
on 60 minutes per diem was featured on
60 minutes who somehow made the
cross-country track one of his earliest
patients she's featured and predict ins
biography and she you know they wheeled
her in and she walked out within a few
weeks she was walking ten miles a day
went on living another thirty one years
they aged 96 after medical death
sentence at age 65 and that's what
that's what changed are all family I
mean now as a kid this was all happen
when I was on I I mean I just well yeah
duh you go to the doctor you get better
that's what doctors do right little did
I know what revolution back then the
thought that heart disease was
reversible completely revolutionary only
later in life did I realized what had
happened what my grandma was part of I
was Pritikin kind of perceived as a
quack in his time well he was I mean he
was putting doctors at shame because he
knew the science because he had he'd
read read all the primary literature and
so with just Tomales there's actually
some old YouTube of his debates he would
just demolish opponents because they
thought they knew what they're talking
about of course they mean they were just
the doctors it weren't odd
anything about nutrition and so I
thought I mean he was just kind of
untouchable when when when who was
actually presenting the science but they
didn't believe his results whose results
were too miraculous and he couldn't
prove it beyond these amazing patient
testimonials but you know how far does
that really go it doesn't until you know
we have good data to back it up and he
inspired everything that you've done I
know that's why I was mad at rigor
that's why I started nutrition facts
that's why I wrote how not to die that's
why all the proceeds ever seen from all
my books are done into charity I just
want to do what everyone for everyone's
family
what Pritikin did for my family right
well let's round this down maybe provide
a few starting points for somebody
that's listening to this this
information is totally new to that
person they're overweight they're ready
for a change what's the first thing they
do go to your local public library grab
how not to diet check it out
and nutritionfacts.org all my work is
free there no ads no corporate
sponsorship strictly non-commercial not
sell anything just put up as a public
service as a labor of love as a tribute
to my grandmother
I like how you mentioned the library and
not the bookstore free books are free
literally in your neighborhood they're
just sitting there but if you had to
tell them like look I'm ready I'm
staring at my next meal like what should
I focus on what am i what what are what
are a couple foods are some like
thumbnail you know rules that I can wrap
my head around yeah so there's a 17
criteria which make for the first part
of the book like being rich in fiber or
water rich vegetables things like that
that that through calorie density
mechanisms and improving microbiome
health is and etc can you know can
achieve that satiety without calorie
restriction or portion control I mean
that's that's the magic of plant-based
eating as opposed additional weight loss
approaches is that you know people are
told to eat ad libitum
meaning eat as much as you want and and
that's because you know you take people
put people on a whole food plant-based
diet and you slash 2,000 calories out of
their daily diet cut their caloric
intake in half
they don't notice because I mean yeah I
mean they have these crazy it put me a
healthy enough that you you just could
some foods you impossible to overeat
2,000 calories of strawberries forty
four cups of strawberries you couldn't
fit them all in your stomach like you
know I mean that you know that's just
you know there's you know me I go on and
on oh listen man I I love you I you know
I can go out and run really far
distances but I aspire to your level of
you know what I mean whatever you got I
want it and you've been so inspiring to
me in my journey and I just I love the
impact that you're having in the world
and and it's it's massive it's no small
thing you've devoted your life to this
cause and you've changed so many other
people's lives and it's to be commended
it's an honor to talk to you today well
you know what I hear beyond just
documentaries I heard you on the rich
roll podcast and that's why I changed my
life and that's why I'm here
good come back again sometime and you're
going to speak at a hospital tonight
that's right where am I gonna pick you
don't even know do you know what state
you're in
I just looked down my phone like oh I'm
going to the airport
oh yeah what's the pitch at the hospital
tonight um we're gonna do weight loss
uh-huh we're gonna do weight loss good
alright now friend let's get you out of
here peace
[Music]
you